[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und eine Gellinek
[Musik]
fernwärme ist das neue Zauberwort der
Ampel denn wer als Verbraucher ans
Fernwärmenetz angeschlossen ist muss ich
keine Sorgen um seine Heizung und deren
CO2-Ausstoß machen der teure Umstieg auf
erneuerbare Energien ist dann das
Problem von Kommunen und Stadtwerken
doof nur dass in Deutschland nur 14% der
Haushalte Fernwärme beziehen und sie
ahnen es die Planung des Netzausbaus
kann dauern insofern kommt der
fernwärmegipfel den Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck und bauministerin gaiwitz in
Berlin veranstalteten ein bisschen spät
Andreas Huppert berichtet
das Müllheizkraftwerk roten See bei
Magdeburg seit 18 Jahren machen sie aus
Müll wertvolle Energie
650.000 Tonnen Abfall jährlich werden
verbrannt umgewandelt in Strom und Wärme
der Abfall die Energie die noch drin
steckt die holen wir da raus die nutzen
wir mit dem man Abfall verbrennen und
damit Wasser erhitzen die Idee ist dass
der Dampf für die Turbine läuft Strom
erzeugt und die Abwärme die nutzen wir
dann zu Erzeugung von Fernwärme damit
versorgen wir im Moment ungefähr so
50.000 Haushalte hier in Magdeburg vor
allem die Fernwärme Weg politische
Begehrlichkeiten lange Zeit eher
stiefmütterlich behandelt in Zeiten
hoher Gas und Ölpreise in Zeiten wo
Energie CO2 neutral und dabei noch
billig werden muss setzt die
Bundesregierung auch auf Fernwärme zum
klimaneutralen Umbau der Wärme
Versorgung
die Fernwärme versorgt in Deutschland
etwa 14 % der Haushalte was wir in 20
Jahren ausbauen können ist dann doch
auch überschaubar es ist ein Teil für
die Energiewende aber es ist nicht die
Lösung für aus alle Haushalte und wir
müssen schauen dass wir die Fernwärme
klimaneutral bekommen das heißt den
Einsatz von Kohle und Erdgas der dort
noch überwiegen stattfindet durch
erneuerbare Energien und Wärmepumpen
ersetzen also auch hier muss noch viel
umgebaut werden deshalb hat der
Wirtschaftsminister zum Gipfel nach
Berlin geladen Verbände Kommunen und den
Verbraucherschutz erstes Treffen erste
Zielvorgabe
100.000 Gebäude sollen jährlich
entfernen beim Systeme angeschlossen
werden das wird natürlich aufwachsend
sein dass während dann nach groben
Schätzungen 400 bis 700.000
Wohneinheiten die dann dort
angeschlossen werden können dazu soll es
ein verlässlichen Rahmen geben der
schließt die Verzahnung mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz ausdrücklich ein heißt
Fernwärme auch als Instrument um das
hochumstrittene Gebäude Energiegesetz zu
entschärfen denn wer künftig auf
Fernwärme umsteigen kann für den
entfällt die Pflicht zum altheizungs-
harmonisieren mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz so dass die Bürgerin
wissen wenn ich in einem Bereich bin wo
Potenzial Fernwärme ausgebaut wird dann
habe ich darüber frühzeitig ein
Informationen und kann meine
individuellen Investitionen darauf
abstimmen apropos abstimmen beim Gebäude
Energiegesetz herrscht noch ordentlich
Zoff in der ampelregierung vor allem die
FDP will weitere Entschärfungen am
Gesetzentwurf
also Kompromisse gibt es derzeit nicht
dafür gibt es ja die Verhandlungen diese
Gespräche finden gerade statt ich
es ist aus meiner Sicht zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht zielführend
in die Details reinzugehen meine Ansicht
nach steht einer politischen Einigung
nicht mehr viel im Weg aber man muss sie
dann natürlich auch wollen und
herstellen
ein Seitenhieb Richtung FDP während die
Bundesregierung also weiter falsch und
streitet machen Sie am Heizkraftwerk
rotensee Nägel mit Köpfen bauen einen
zusätzlichen Kraftwerksblock um in der
Region Magdeburg dann im nächsten Jahr
noch mehr Haushalte mit Strom und
Fernwärme versorgen zu können
und uns und uns ist jetzt unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent Theo Colt
zugeschaltet guten Abend theo war dieses
Treffen in Berlin eigentlich heute mehr
als ein Robert Habeck gerettet seinen
rufgipfel
ja das war durchaus mehr als ein rettet
den Robert Termin es kann ja ein
wichtiger Teil oder ein Teil der
künftigen werbeversorgung des Landes
werden aktuell wird ja nur jeder siebte
Wohnung mit Fernwärme versorgt am Ende
soll es jede dritte sein die Absurdität
auch für havix ruft die liegt ja in der
falschen zeitlichen Reihenfolge man
stelle sich einmal vor die
fernwärmepläne wären als erstes den
Bürgern vorgelegt worden mit präzisen
Straßenkarten wer wo künftig mit
Fernwärme versorgt werden soll dann
hätten beim Gebäude Energiegesetz ja
viele Menschen erleichtert festgestellt
dass sie die Umstellung der Heizung kaum
noch betrifft weil sie es quasi
auslagern können auf Ihre Kommune denn
die muss dann für Fernwärme mit
erneuerbaren Energiequellen sorgen so
aber ist quasi der habe ich im Brunnen
und das wird ein längerer Weg da wieder
rauszukommen die fernwärmepläne wenn sie
denn vorliegen werden die Minister
zumindest dabei helfen denn sie sollten
einen Teil des Drucks nehmen
dies ist ja die Woche der Entscheidung
über das heizungsgesetz noch wird
offenbar verhandelt werden es gerade
gehört bislang offen war auch ohne
Ergebnis was heißt das jetzt für die
ampelregierung wenn das Gesetz morgen
nicht auf die Tagesordnung des
Bundestages kommt
dann wäre ein geordnetes Verfahren für
das Gesetz also mit Zeit für
parlamentarische Debatten nicht mehr
möglich und genau das war ja von der
Koalition ausdrücklich gewollt
theoretisch könnte man das Gesetz mit
allen drei Lesungen aber auch noch
Anfang Juli in der allerletzten
parlamentswoche vor der Sommerpause
durchpeitschen das hat es durchaus schon
gegeben noch wird verhandelt und die
Koalitionspartner halten ziemlich dicht
ich sage Ihnen mal was ich aus
unterschiedlichen Quellen gehört habe
was unter anderem gerade diskutiert
werde bei den Grünen herrscht zum
Beispiel Sorge das Gas nur noch nur
durch Gas ersetzt werde also dass man im
Gesetz zwar
wasserstofffähige Gasheizung zulassen
aber dann nicht für ausreichend
wasserstoffsorge und somit es zu lange
beim Gasbetrieb bleibe und SPD
Abgeordnete haben den Vorschlag
eingebracht den Einsatz von erneuerbaren
zunächst auf Neubauten zu begrenzen
interessanterweise unterstellen sich
Grüne und FDP Moment
gegenseitig mangelnde Geschlossenheit
aus der FDP ist zu hören habe ich sei ja
kompromissbereit aber Teile der Grünen
nicht und wie geschlossen die FDP sei
das sei ja auch fraglich sagt die andere
Seite so viel zu politischer Fernwärme
es bleibt also schwierig danke für diese
Einordnung aus Berlin
eine fiktive Militärallianz aus
Osteuropa namens ockersus greift den
Rostocker Hafen an die NATO ruft
daraufhin den Bündnisfall aus Samt
Einsatz von Spezialkräften und
Aktivierung der Luftverteidigung das ist
das Szenario das in den nächsten zehn
Tagen über Deutschland geübt wird er
Defender 23 ist ein Manöver der
Superlative 25 Nationen 250 Flugzeuge
10.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten geplant
wurde diese Großübung lange vor dem
Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine und
die Luftwaffe wird nicht müde zu betonen
dass die trainingsabsicht rein
verteidigen sei trotzdem wirkt dass
Manöver beklemmend aktuell Thomas
Reichert berichtet
es beginnt am Morgen mit dem Aufmarsch
der Transportflieger Wunstorf in
Niedersachsen ist das Logistikzentrum
des Manövers und diese Maschinen so
etwas wie seine Sattelschlepper von
anderen Standorten starten kurz darauf
Kampfjets nach Litauen die erste
Botschaft am ersten Tag geht Richtung
Russland das ist das was unsere
östlichen Bündnispartner verlangen diese
Rückversicherung dass wir zeigen auch
sie sind natürlich Teil integraler
Bestandteil dieser NATO und so ist er
Defender nicht nur eine mega Übung die
Verteidigung gegen ein fiktiven
Angreifer aus dem Osten der bereits
Teile Deutschlands eingenommen hat es
ist mindestens so sehr eine Art selbst
Vergewisserung gerade für Deutschland
dass die Federführung bei diesem Manöver
hat
wir wissen seit dem russischen Überfall
auf die Ukraine dass die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur so wie sie über
Jahrzehnte lang von uns unterstellt
worden ist eben nicht mehr funktioniert
und dass deswegen die Landesverteidigung
ganz zwingend eine wesentlich größere
Bedeutung haben muss der Aufwand der
dafür betrieben wird ist enorm allein
der Treibstoff für die rund 250
Flugzeuge in Wunstorf mussten sie dafür
ein riesiges mobiles kerosinlager bauen
meine Kompanie ist hier seit der zweiten
Kalenderwoche also seit Anfang Januar
2023 hier im Einsatz wir haben insgesamt
17.000 Tonnen Schotter bewegt knapp zwei
Kilometer an Rohrleitungen im Endeffekt
verlegt und sind jetzt in der Lage 2,4
Millionen Liter Kraftstoff also hier
Kerosin zu lagern den größten Anteil
stellen mit rund 100 Flugzeugen wie
immer die USA er Defender ist da nicht
anders als die NATO für seine Sicherheit
braucht Europa Amerika
wenn wir wissen wie ich heute erfahren
habe dass die amerikanischen Soldaten
und Soldaten innerhalb von wenigen Tagen
von 10 Tagen hierhin verlegt haben nach
Wunstorf und in die übungsgebiete dann
gibt uns das auch ein Gefühl von
Sicherheit die Verspätungen für den
zivilen Luftverkehr hielten sich
zumindest an diesem ersten Tag offenbar
in Grenzen dafür gab es schon zuvor
Proteste der Friedensbewegung gegen die
Übung und auch die Linke hält es für das
falsche Zeichen für eine Provokation in
der Richtung Putin es ist ein
militärisches seberrasseln dass wir für
unverantwortlich halten gerade jetzt wo
ein Krieg in Europa tobt ist doch der
Eskalation das Gebot der Stunde
Diplomatie und nicht Aufrüstung
militärische Machtdemonstration und das
befeuern der Eskalationsspirale die Luft
war für dagegen betont dass Manöver
richte sich gegen niemanden es geht
darum die eigene Verteidigung zu üben
das Signal bleibt der noch unüberhörbar
der Westen rüstet sich gegen die
Bedrohung aus Russland
darüber wollen wir reden mit unserem
nato-korrespondenten Florian Neuhann in
Brüssel Florian da wehte ja ein Hauch
von kaltem Krieg über Deutschland bei
dieser Übung welches Signal geht von
diesem Manöver aus
ich würde sagen mindestens drei Signale
das erste geht von den NATO-Staaten
eindeutig in Richtung Russland dieses
Manöver wurde ja geplant bereits vor dem
Krieg 2018 aber damals bereits in die
Reaktion auf russische Aggression
nämlich auf die russische Eroberung der
Krim und jetzt kommt es der NATO eben
erst recht gelegen als Signal der
Abschreckung an Wladimir Putin und das
ist fast genauso wie damals im Kalten
Krieg das zweite Signal dann das wird
hier in Brüssel sehr genau registriert
und zwar ein Signal von Deutschland an
die anderen NATO-Staaten das auch die
deutsche Luftwaffe und Bundeswehr bereit
und in der Lage ist sich an der
gemeinsamen bündnisverteidigung zu
beteiligen denn daran gab es ja durchaus
angesichts des Zustand ist der
Bundeswehr berechtigte Zweifel und diese
Zweifel will man eben mit einem solchen
großen Manöver zumindest teilweise
ausräumen und das dritte Signal darüber
wird hier auch durchaus offen gesprochen
ist eines an die eigene auch an die
deutsche Bevölkerung dass diese
zeitenwände eben real ist und dass die
Verteidigung auch durch aus Geld kostet
die EU hat ja in den letzten Jahren
ziemlich viel von europäischer
Souveränität gesprochen und dabei
durchaus auch die militärische
Eigenständigkeit gemeint könnten die
Europäer eigentlich auch allein einem
solchen simulierten Angriff Russlands
etwas entgegensetzen
muss man sagen dass er seit dem Beginn
des russischen Krieges viel investiert
worden ist in die eigene Verteidigung
man denke einfach auch an das
Sondervermögen für die deutsche
Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden Euro aber
dieses Manöver ist wirklich ein
eindrucksvoller belegt dafür wie
abhängig man ist militärisch von der
Stärke der USA die Hälfte der Flugzeuge
der Kampfjet kommt eben aus den USA die
modernsten dazu diese F35 Kampfjets und
das nähert natürlich die Sorge was würde
passieren wenn im nächsten Jahr in den
USA ein Präsident gewählt werden sollte
der deutlich weniger von der NATO hält
als der aktuelle und darauf ist Europa
schlicht nicht vorbereitet
danke nach Brüssel
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula Gause und bei
dir geht es weiter mit einem Treffen in
Paris
Frankreichs Präsident macron berät zur
Stunde mit Polens Staatschef duda und
Bundeskanzler Scholz über die weitere
militärische Unterstützung der Ukraine
Scholz erklärte russlands Präsident
Putin habe die Einigkeit der Europäer
unterschätzt bei den Beratungen in Paris
geht es auch um
nato-perspektiven und
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
ebenso wie um eine Ausweitung der
humanitären Hilfe nach der Beschädigung
des kachowka Staudamms ausführlich
berichtet später unser heute journal
Update über das Treffen
die führenden deutschen
friedensforschungsinstitute sehen im
Krieg gegen die Ukraine keinen anderen
Ausweg als das Überfallene Land weiter
militärisch zu unterstützen ein Ende der
russischen Gewalt zeichne sich nicht ab
sagen sie in ihrem friedensgutachten
Moskau setze weiter auf Expansion
deutschland müsse aber dabei helfen eine
internationale verhandlungsinitiative
vorzubereiten
im Zuge ihrer Gegenoffensive melden die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte weitere kleine
Gelände Gewinne im Gebiet Donetzk nach
Einschätzung von
us-militärexperten geht es in der
Anfangsphase der Gegenoffensive darum
Schwachstellen in der russischen
Verteidigung aufzuspüren zugleich
berichtet das russische Militär
Angriffsversuche ukrainischer Truppen
abgewehrt zu haben fast eine Woche nach
der Zerstörung des kachowka Staudamms
sinkt der Wasserstand im überfluteten
Kriegsgebiet weiter noch aber stehen 46
Siedlungen unter Wasser
das schwedische
Friedensforschungsinstitut sie priv
waren vor der steigenden Zahl
einsatzfähige Atomwaffen zwar sei die
Zahl von mehr als
9.500 noch weit entfernt von den mehr
als 70.000 während der 1980er Jahre aber
nuklear Diplomatie sei dringend ebenso
wie eine Verstärkung der internationalen
die USA wollen der
un-kulturorganisation UNESCO wieder
beitreten unter Präsident Trump hatten
sie sich 2018 aus der UNESCO
zurückgezogen und zuvor schon wegen
eines Streits über den Nahostkonflikt
die Beiträge ausgesetzt jetzt kündigte
unesco-generaldirektorin azulär an
Washington wolle beim Wiedereintritt im
Juli 600 Millionen Dollar an offenen
Zahlungen begleichen offenbar wollen
sich die USA so Möglichkeiten erhalten
Einfluss auf Entscheidungen zu nehmen
etwa zu Standards für künstliche
Intelligenz
Milliardär Medienmogul Macho aber auch
politischer Strippenzieher Populist
einer der die rechten Parteien Italiens
salonfähig machte das alles war Silvio
Berlusconi viermal wurde er zum
italienischen Ministerpräsidenten
gewählt und noch viel öfter angeklagt
wegen Schmiergeldzahlungen Bestechung
und Steuerhinterziehung nur wegen seines
hohen Alters musste er am Ende nicht ins
Gefängnis Putin nannte er bis zum
Schluss einen Freund sich selbst
bescheiden den Jesus Christus der
Politik heute ist der in Mailand
gestorben Andreas Postel berichtet
nicht überall in Italien ist die
Anteilnahme an diesem Tag so groß wie
vor Silvio Berlusconis Privatvilla in
Akkorde als der Leichnam des 86-jährigen
aus der Mailänder Klinik hierher
gebracht wird
Verbündete wie Gegner aber sprechen an
diesem Tag vom Ende einer
Ära
ein großer Mann ein großer Unternehmer
gewieft gerissen der für viel Glanz und
viel Arbeit gesorgt hat
meiner Meinung nach wäre es besser
gewesen wenn er nicht da gewesen wäre es
waren dunkle Jahre mit ihm Kommissionen
Untersuchungen er hat uns nie gut
aussehen lassen
menschlichen Standpunkt aus muss ich
sagen dass eine Ära vorbei ist und man
weiß nicht was jetzt auf uns zukommt
entweder man hat ihn geliebt oder
gehasst Silvio Berlusconi der Erfinder
des politischen Populismus sein letzter
Erfolg das von ihm geschmiedete mit der
rechtsbündnis 2022 zwar wird Georgia
Meloni Ministerpräsidentin doch ohne ihn
wäre sie nicht da er hat die extreme
Rechte salonfähig gemacht
[Musik]
il Cavaliere prägte Italien über drei
Jahrzehnte vom medienmodul zum
Multimillionär bis zum
Ministerpräsidenten und das viermal
angetreten war Berlusconi 1994 angeblich
um das korrupte Italien zu erneuern als
Politiker nutzte er hemmungslos seine
Medien macht die drei größten
Privatsender des Landes gehörten ihm
Zeitungen Verlage der Fußballclub AC
Milan mit den mächtigen zeigte er sich
gern besonders mit Wladimir Putin den er
auch nach dem Angriff auf die Ukraine
als Freund bezeichnete
auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Macht war er
ein Unikum kaum jemand hätte damals
gedacht dass sein Politikstil einmal
prominente Nachahmer in Europa und den
USA finden würde was Trump später konnte
das konnte Berlusconi schon lange
sie trennte Welten und vergessen
Auftritt in Deutschland als er Angela
Merkel auf offener Bühne demonstrativ
und Minuten lang warten ließ
seine zahlreichen gesetzeskonflikte
Schienen an ihm abzuperlen wie oft
Teflon die Vorwürfe zahlreich Bestechung
betrug Steuerhinterziehung doch nicht
die Skandale und wilde Bunga Bunga
Partys sondern die Wirtschaftskrise
verursacht auch durch jahrelang
verschlepptere Formen treiben ihn
schließlich aus dem Amt
berlusconi hat Italien gespalten in
Gegner und glühende Anhänger doch so
widersprüchlich das klingen mag damit
war er über drei Jahrzehnte ein
stabilisierender Faktor und brachte es
in Italiens zersplitterte
Parteienlandschaft auf die längste
Amtszeit in der italienischen
Nachkriegsgeschichte
sein Führungsstil so Italiens
Staatspräsident habe dazu beigetragen
eine neue Geographie der italienischen
Politik zu formen
und zu hinterlässt Berlusconi ein
machtvacum dass Italiens politische
Landschaft erneut in Bewegung versetzen
kann
Wladimir Putin wird an der Beerdigung
seines Freundes belusconi am Mittwoch
nicht teilnehmen können er würde in
Italien wegen des Haftbefehls des
Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs sofort
festgenommen
bei uns geht's jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula und einem
Dauerbrenner die Tarifverhandlungen bei
der Deutschen Bahn sind in eine neue
Runde gestartet bis Freitag sind die
Gespräche angesetzt und bis dahin soll
es keine neuen Warnstreiks geben die EVG
verwies allerdings erneut auf die hohe
streitbereitschaft innerhalb der
Gewerkschaft DB Personalvorstand Seiler
hofft auf eine tragfähige Lösung
allerdings seien die Differenzen immer
noch groß
eine der weltweit bedeutendsten
bankenübernahmen ist unter Dach und Fach
die Schweizer UBS hat den angeschlagenen
Rivalen creditsuisse übernommen die
Transaktion ist abgeschlossen weil die
Halle die neue UBS hat nun mehrere
Billionen Dollar zu verwalten welche
Risiken sehen die Finanzmärkte ja die
neue UBS ist einfach ein banken-koloss
ein Monster wie die neue Züricher
Zeitung schreibt und man fragt sich hier
schon wer soll die eigentlich retten die
Schweiz jedenfalls ist dafür zu klein
ein Blick auf die Zahlen die neue UBS
hat eine Bilanzsumme von 1,6 Billionen
Dollar doppelt so viel wie die jährliche
Schweizer Wirtschaftsleistung die
Zwangsfusion ist heute formal
abgeschlossen die richtige Arbeit die
beginnt jetzt erst zwei Riesen
zusammenzuführen die Jahrzehnte lang
Schafe Konkurrenten waren das würde ein
Herkules Aufgabe das kostet
Arbeitsplätze weil es jede Menge
Doppelbesetzungen gibt 10 Prozent sind
schon gegangen weitere werden folgen
auch wird die Bank weil sie so riesig
ist mit harten Regularien rechnen müssen
dicke Kapitalpuffer beispielsweise
welche Folgen werden denn die Kunden
dieses Giganten spüren oder zu tragen
haben nun das sind ganz ganz unruhige
Zeiten für die Bank viel Energie geht in
den Umbau manchmal vielleicht auch auf
Kosten der Kundenpflege zu kurz könnten
auch Investitionen Innovation und
Wachstum kommen denn so eine Fusion ist
teuer und dass der Zusammenschluss von
zwei großen Banken für die Aktionäre
einen Mehrwert schafft dass es auch noch
keine ausgemachte Sache vielen Dank
Valerie nach Frankfurt
seit fast 100 Jahren ist der zweitgrößte
US-Autohersteller Ford in Deutschland
präsent nun wollen die Amerikaner
hierzulande Elektroautos produzieren
offiziell eröffnet wurde das rund 2
Milliarden Euro teure Werk heute im
Beisein von Bundeskanzler Scholz noch in
diesem Jahr soll in Köln das erste
vollelektrische Modell vom Band rollen
eine Personalie aus der
Fußball-Bundesliga Dino topmelder einst
Profi bei Eintracht Frankfurt kehrt
jetzt als neuer Cheftrainer an den Main
zurück der 42-Jährige folgt auf Oliver
Glasner und erhält einen Vertrag bis
2026 bis März war Topmodelle Co-Trainer
beim FC Bayern München
es war ein Freundschaftsspiel ein Spiel
der Solidarität mit der Ukraine dass die
Nationalmannschaft am frühen Abend in
Bremen bestritten hat aber auch ein
wichtiger und ernst zu nehmender
Leistungstest das hart erkämpfte drei zu
drei Unentschieden in ihrem tausendsten
Länderspiel regt sportlich gesehen zu
neuer Motivation an zu neuen Tempo
vielleicht auch zu neuer Aufstellung
freundschaftlich war es und bleibt es
die Einnahmen der Partie gehen als
Spende an die von Russland angegriffene
Ukraine
[Musik]
es ist eine einigermaßen skurrile
Allianz die Altrocker Udo Lindenberg
mittlerweile 77 mit dem Rapper Apache
207 eingegangen ist der Mann ist 25
Zweck der Verbindung war natürlich für
beide einen Hit zu platzieren der in den
jeweiligen Zielgruppen Erfolg hat und
dieser Plan ist voll aufgegangen mit dem
Duett Komet schaffte Udo Lindenberg es
auf seine alten Tage zum ersten Mal auf
Platz 1 der Single Charts
hochkatapultiert vom vermutlich gerade
erfolgreichsten deutschen Musiker Apache
207 kommt aus Ludwigshafen und hat mal
zwei Semester Jura studiert ansonsten
gibt er wenig von sich preis bis er
jetzt unseren Kollegen Jan Frederick
Fischer und Anna gürt ein Interview gab
ihm folgen online Millionen Apache 207
was er von sich zeigt entscheidet er am
liebsten selbst solche Momente bisher
privat fremde Kameras um sich herum mag
er eigentlich nicht bis jetzt
Mikrofon die Nervosität ist groß das
Release-Konzert zum neuen Album beginnt
in wenigen Sekunden
[Musik]
der bisher größte Hit auf dem Album der
Song Komet zusammen mit Udo Lindenberg
[Musik]
der Udo der hat mir schon vor zwei
Jahren oder so eine Mail geschrieben du
warst du so super easy super cool aus
dem Nichts nach ganz oben das Phänomen
Apache 2019 wird der Song Roller ein
riesen Erfolg 100 millionenfach
gestreamt kein Lied war jemals länger in
den deutschen Single Charts
aus wenn unsere Roller wieder schneiden
nun das Album Gartenstadt ein Hommage an
das Viertel aus dem er kommt in Mannheim
geboren im benachbarten Ludwigshafen auf
seine alleinerziehende Mutter gibt ihn
den Spitznamen Apache als Kind aus
relativ schweren Verhältnissen war halt
das perfekte Bild immer ey und wenn ich
das hätte und wenn ich das hätte und
wenn ich das hätte aber alles voll geil
aber irgendwann hat man das erreicht und
dann ist aber die Ernüchterung sehr sehr
groß dann ist alles da ist und irgendwie
das alltägliche Leben nicht sich besser
anfühlt Straßen Rap trifft auf
melancholische blockromantik und jede
Menge Herzschmerz
Apache schreibt Songs in denen sich
jeder wiederfinden kann
und provoziert trotzdem
[Applaus]
[Musik]
von seinem Handy zugleich wandelt der
Künstler zwischen den Genres mal 80's
top mal Europeans im Hip Hop verwurzelt
und immer ein Augenzwinkern
wir mit den Jungs müssen so das ist
einfach unser Ding ist unsere Art und
Weise uns auszudrücken unser Humor ist
einfach geil in seinen Texten geht es
auch um Zweifel jenseits des
Rampenlichts wir fragen warum er
trotzdem hadert immer ganz genau den
Zeilen Horst geht eigentlich gar nicht
darum mit dem Erfolg zu haben sondern
[Musik]
mit der mit der Gewissheit der
Endlichkeit sozusagen klar zu kommen
weil ihr jeder Höhenflug oder jeder Hype
auch irgendwann mal sein Ende hat nach
dem Konzert verschwindet der Patsche in
der Menge bis er wieder ein Blick hinter
die Kulissen zulässt wird es dauern
erstmal schreibt er seine Geschichte auf
seinen Kanälen selbst weiter
und wir sind auch endlich das was von
uns das ganze Interview mit Apache 207
können Sie ab heute Nacht in der ZDF
Mediathek sehen und um 0 Uhr ist jetzt
Zeit für Nazan gökte mir mit unserem
heute journal Update und wir sind morgen
wieder für Sie da schönen Abend und
tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend droht uns eine blitzdürre
üblicherweise dort der Boden über Monate
oder gar Jahre aus manchmal geht es
deutlich schneller innerhalb weniger
Wochen erleben wir im kleinen gerade
hier bei uns trotz des nassen Frühjahrs
des bis in die tiefen durchfeuchteten
Bodens erst zogen die Wurzeln Wasser aus
dem Boden die Vegetation wuchs und
gedieht und gab über die Blätter die
feuchte wieder ab seit Ende Mai
stagniert die Wetterlage Sonne
Trockenheit und viel Wind beschleunigen
die Verdunstung saugen Tag für Tag
Wasser aus dem Boden schnell verdorrte
Oberboden später trockenen tiefere
Bodenschichten aus Wald und
vegetationsbrände sowie Ernteausfälle
drohen
auch morgen ist die Waldbrandgefahr sehr
hoch hier im Nordosten aber auch im
Südwesten Deutschlands und die
Hoffnungen ruhen auf einem kleinen Tiefe
über Polen das zunächst mal ein paar
Wolken aber zur Wochenmitte dann auch
Regenschauer und Gewitter zumindest mal
in den Osten Deutschlands bringen heute
Nacht ist es klar und die Temperaturen
sinken auf 16 bis 7 Grad morgen strahlt
wieder die Sonne nur Nordosten gibt's
schon einige Wolken bei Ost bis
Nordostwind die Temperaturen steigen auf
20 Grad hier im südlichen Brandenburg
und bis 29 Grad am Niederrhein an diesem
Wetter ändert sich im Westen
Deutschlands nichts im Osten aber gibt's
die angesprochenen Regenschauer und
Gewitter guten Abend